it is wonderful to see all of you
thank you thank you thank you there you
are i try to practice your hello by
saying
let me try get closer hello
we are gravity do they do it right
here you are with your third album how
would you say
gravity has grown and who you are and
your sound and your vibe
now after being together for a few years
oh i feel like gravity
we always try to we always try out new
music
do styles of genres with every release
and so we always try to make it our own
so then i feel like that's what makes us
stand out among other groups
and also our teamwork and performance is
on another level it is yes
and your album is called hideout be our
voice
very powerful i i mean for you to be
able to put this album out
um has it been influenced by your fans
lovety
even everyone
influence us in our music and our
performances and also
house hiring i and once you took part in
writing the lyrics of a few songs or
albums
right we always think about them we
always consider
like how they accept their lyrics how
they'll like
how they react to our music yeah
it's beautiful and your song my turn is
absolutely amazing the video is amazing
uh how long does it take for you to
learn those dance routines how long are
you practicing
usually it takes two days for
memorize the move and for example our
b size um it takes one week
to go up stage yeah yeah just one week
wow and who's who's the responsible one
who's the big brother in the group
big brother
what do you love about the fashion
because you guys have a statement just
by what you're wearing so how would you
describe
your look
it's a little bit futuristic
and like
you have been called the rookie of the
year in terms of last year and everyone
is calling you the next
big k-pop group how does that feel
people think you guys
are amazing
[Music]
[Laughter]
you must be so excited it's really such
an honor
it feels so good that our hard work is
being recognized
and you know that with greater
expectation comes greater burden
but despite of all that we're always
making sure we're on top of our game
that we're always putting out the best
yeah it's so well said and k-pop music
has become
loved around the world everyone loves
k-pop and
all these bands have done so much these
groups have done so well from bts
blackpink and collaborations with like
lady gaga dua lipa who do you want to
collaborate with
i want to collaborate with charlie puss
because i
saw him making the music
or writing songs yeah it was so cool
super cool anyone else
and sarah astrid yes and anybody else is
it alan do you have a choice uh i want
to collaborate with like edm artists
eating
djs artists but changeable bursts yeah
chase workers
you know now that you've been in a band
together uh
what's your advice to other people who
may want to make k-pop music
i say for me i say to
look at me oh follow follow michael
steps
because i was once in their position as
well as a young boy
who had dreams who had who aspired to be
a k-pop star
and you know to look at me and to see
that you know if i could do it
you could do it
i'm curious what who do you listen to
who's your favorite artist right now
what's right
and i asked your fans levity to i was
saying that i was going to talk to you
today and ask for questions for you
and they want to know which one of you
are single
hands up
[Music]
so only a few of you are single which is
good um
what would you like to say to your fans
love it i mean they just
absolutely adore you what what would you
say to them about their support
[Music]
thank you for always supporting us and
we also always think about what it is
how to
get improve ourselves and how to
push it up how do you how do you make
yes touched
so yeah doing our best so thank you
i love you guys oh that's so sweet
and how has your family and friends feel
about all your success
uh my friends honestly
uh not work of my career
then they're not aware of this review
how are they not aware
[Music]
my parents are very proud of me but my
friends
are didn't know
yeah what do you do for fun
what do we do for what do we do for fun
exercise
what's your favorite movie right now
you guys are amazing thank you for
chatting with me today i really
appreciate it and congratulations on all
your success
and i'm looking forward to listening to
your whole album and thank you so much
thank you so much we have a good time
with you and at et canada thanks for
having us